you're watching game for this series we
certainly saw plenty of
[Applause]
yesterday there was a teleconference
Bucs coach Mike Budenholzer was asked
about Drake
being so visible on the sidelines and he
tried to play it off and really not go
there eventually he did answer the
question and so everybody in the world's
been talking about this today I don't
know how much it needs on the court it
sounds like you guys are saying it's
more than I realized
there's certainly no place for fans and
you know whatever it is exactly that
that Drake is for the Toronto Raptors
you know to be on the court you know
there's there's boundaries and lines for
a reason so Charles I'll begin with you
because everybody has been talking about
Drake and how excited he was and given
the given Nick nurse a little background
at one point and so what do you make of
all this well I was disappointed and
code button house would be either wit
onyx with you
listen man you need to be worried about
normal Powell Marc Gasol and Serge Ibaka
listen nobody's paying attention
I like Drake I think he's great for the
game but for NBA close to be worrying
about that instead of like he should
have said hey guys I ain't worried about
Drake I'm worried about the Toronto
Raptors and that's I wish what he would
have said so you think he could have
just diffused this by just say no
yeah he got defeated what happened was
he was asked a question he was asked a
question she's been professor he
answered that's the way he felt wasn't
complaining about it but you're right
don't worry you're making it seem like
he was complaining he was complaining
his answering the question there's a
difference between the answer the
question and then you're just coming out
doing the press he could could it defuse
the situation because let's be honest
you know everyone doesn't get treated
the same everyone gets treated fairly
and no other person in that arena every
Raptor comes and gives a high-five - no
one else in that arena everyone pays
into - no one else in that arena we
actually put a camera on so yes he does
get treated that no one else has their
name on the practice facility but I'm
pretty sure they'd be worried about
those shoes were much behind my stuff
I'm covered about no Drake yes I've
asked you a question as a player would
you be concerned no no I wouldn't either
oh no either all right then so what what
what I would do I would say Kenny do me
a favor throw the ball out of bounds one
time and I'd knock the hell out of drink